yeah you can even see the impact of
drivers right now behind me you see the
15 far beyond my shoulder and we're in
front of the Dean Martin right now which
is also seeing some backups and that
impact is not only impacting drivers but
also businesses along this stretch which
I spoke to today and they say they're
seeing the impact already
we're going to lose those people for
right now but I think ultimately it's
going to be much better businesses
around Tropicana are feeling a mix of
effects from the project Kyle Collins is
general manager at Tommy rockers and
says more traffic may mean more
customers for his restaurant it's
actually pushed a lot of people towards
this way it's a lot of you know
businesses that are nearby obviously
don't want to go traveling because it's
been construction they don't want to
deal with the heck of this so so far
it's been good Steve Levesque with
Hollywood cars is planning ahead Dean
Martin's open so that's not a problem
but if they're getting over uh they can
come over the Hacienda bridge and kind
of come come around the back way just
making people aware of what we're about
to go through the next three days with
that part of the 15 shutting down
telling the staff hey you know prep a
little early and maybe leave a little
you know 15 20 minutes earlier than you
would overall both businesses said they
feel like the finished construction will
be worth the wait we can tell from the
plans that it's going to be much much
better
once they get finished I think going to
leave you a lot of pressure on both
sides of the ball when it comes to
traveling either being locally or just
going through through Las Vegas
I also spoke to several truckers today
who said they do have alternate routes
planned to be prepared for traffic like
this reporting near Tropicana Brian will
8 news now and